Let's talk about love.
But when it comes to love, I have a show in "Single By 30".
This is an album originally created by Youtube Red.
It is now in the heat!
Ok, I know how to fall in love.
There should be no more than one right.
Some people are together because of rationality
Socially economically and intellectually
We are very commensurate
I agree that we should be partners
I also agree with this conclusion.
We should start from today and start kissing next week.
Then start making love in a month
I am a more confident person.
I ask you to consider three weeks before we start making love.
I will consider looking
Transaction
thank you
you are welcome
Some people will be together for convenience
You are very close to me, you are my person.
We are together
Then I have to admit that when I like someone,
I am the kind of person I am.
I will fall in love at first sight.
Elysia, I didn’t do anything.
Have! You are there!
Nothing!
*Fantasy*
Are you listening to Ah?
That feeling is very strong
When I fell in love, I really fell into it...
Water is good ice!
I know what you are going to say?
Save it! I already know what you want to say.
That’s not love, it’s just a flower idiot.
It’s just that desire is just a delusion.
Yeah, I admit that I am thinking about it.
I met a person and started to fantasize
Fantasy that he is a good person
Then we will be perfect if we are together
How beautiful will we have for the rest of our lives?
In a wonderful marriage
When he said nothing:
Hi, I am called a mustache.
But what I heard is:
I won't mind if you have a few cats.
Because I didn't fall in love with this person.
I fell in love with this concept.
I am "love" a person
No matter how many warnings he shows
In fact, I don't think it is necessary to have a monogamy.
I am carrying a girl who has been dating before.
I don't want to raise a child.
I refuse to find a job and I don't want to help people.
That's why I haven't paid taxes for about four years.
Oh
Can you wait for me?
Pretty sure it was my girlfriend’s call.
Hey
I gradually learned about this after I grew up.
I have judged more than before.
Now I meet people who have eyes, I will think
All these feelings are not love
It’s just being attracted by the opposite sex.
Are all Hormons
I like you~ I like you~
Oh! I also like you~
Oh~ I like you~
Handsome guy, where are you going~ I like you~
I like you~ Hey! I like you~
Then I like you too~
But maybe you are a reasonable person.
Will only fall in love with those
I have known for a long time
Already know their advantages
Friend of people
It’s like Harry and Kina in "Single By 30"
The transition animation on Youtube Red is very smooth.
That transition animation is really smooth
I am honored to play Harry Shum's
My sister is called Grace in "Single By 30"
This is a painful but lovely romantic comedy on WongFU.
Now the entire chapter can be found on Youtube Red.
So don't forget to rush your subscription.
You may see me in the play or around Christmas.
Or who knows sometime next year?
I may be able to occupy the entire Youtube Red flat
Ok, then
I am Anna Akana.
I actually said my name wrong.